you're 15 and somebody tells you they
love you
Jennifer Lopez's twins celebrate a
milestone birthday but rare footage of
the kids with Ben Affleck now that's a
gift for everyone I'm ready I'm excited
about it yeah JLo's little ones aren't
so little these days Max and Emmy turned
15 years old on Instagram she wishes
happy birthday to my beautiful brilliant
coconuts
foreign
plus Jennifer shears a heartwarming
Montage to Taylor Swift's ballad 15
featuring JLo the twins dad Mark Anthony
and Ben
[Music]
she tells her kids I am so proud of you
both in every single way you bring so
much joy and happiness to my heart and
soul I love you beyond forever they are
so big and so amazing and happy this
comes as we're learning about Max and
Emmy's Dynamic with Ben's children
Violet Seraphina and Samuel whom he
shares with ex Jennifer Garner
in December A source told E.T the five
kids are doing great and get along
effortlessly quote they all really have
respect for each other Jennifer's
relationship with Ben's kids is natural
and same goes for Ben's bond with
Jennifer's kids we're super happy
um what can I tell you and get this the
family keeps getting bigger two weeks
after Mark Anthony married Nadia
Ferreira the newlyweds announced they're
expecting he's such a loving father and
he's just a good person it'll be the
seventh child for the Latin pop star who
previously tied the knot with JLo in
2004. I give it away but it has a very
good ending shortly after benifer 1.0
went their separate ways
speaking with E.T at the time Ben even
sent his best wishes I'm very happy for
her so I wish her and mark the very very
best fast forward to 2023
prefer 2.0 is thriving
as if walking down the aisle wasn't
enough they doubled down with some
tattoos Jen's an infinity symbol with a
Cupid's arrow and both their names in
cursive Ben's Crossing Arrows with their
initials
[Music]
but in a month full of tributes the best
one celebrates their family's next
chapter
[Music]